hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2015 american superhero and comedy movie
called american hero
the movie begins with a man in a
wheelchair named lucille searching
around new orleans looking for a
middle-aged man called melvin
nearby people admit that melvin is a
loser who should stop doing everything
he has been doing
lucille is being followed by a cameraman
who wants to make a movie about melvin
after a long search the crippled man
spots melvin's shoe and eventually finds
melvin sleeping on the street acting
like a homeless man
turns out that melvin has to attend
court after his ex-wife doreen filed a
restraining order against him they
immediately rush home and melvin dresses
up
he practices several lines of the plea
he has prepared before but somehow it
doesn't seem promising at all
after that melvin arrives at the
courthouse and goes to the courtroom in
confidence
a few moments later he returns to his
buddy but shows a very desperate face
he reveals that he is sentenced to a
community service order and his wife
doreen has taken sole custody of their
son rex
melvin approaches her and scolds her but
she doesn't care and drives away with
her son
without remorse he then goes to his
friend's place and gets drunk there
turns out that he is also an alcoholic
and drug abuser in the middle of the
party he is approached by a college
science teacher lucas who has performed
several medical check-ups on melvin
since he has been possessing a weird
telekinesis power which allows him to
move objects using only his mind he
discovers that there's a slight
difference in melvin's brain compared to
a normal human's brain
meanwhile luke tells the cameraman that
while serving in iraq in 1991 he got hit
by a sniper which caused permanent
damage on his leg and he has to spend
his entire life in a wheelchair
his wife left him and melvin was the
only person who let him stay with him
and his mother
this shows that melvin is actually a
kind-hearted man
melvin luke and a friend called lyle to
perform a street magic show to gain some
money where melvin magically manages to
lift luke's wheelchair without landing a
single finger on it which amazes the
nearby people back at home melvin's mom
is aware of his son's ability as he
sometimes accidentally lifts the
furniture without him realizing that
he also likes to bother his sister with
his telekinesis power
a neighbor of melvin claims that he once
helped her to repair her house with his
power but it seems like it's the only
case when he helps people with his
ability
he goes to a scrap yard to perform his
power to the cameraman
the trio go to a drug dealer to spend
all their money on drugs the leader
nathan insults luke and melvin for no
reason but they ignore him and walk away
with peace
instead of using his power for greater
good melvin frequently uses his
telekinesis ability to tease women and
gets high again and again
the next day he begins his first day
doing community service with a teenager
during the break time he performs a
simple magic trick that amuses the
teenager
he then brings the cameraman to his room
where he briefly shows him his son's
life journey he continues living his
boring life as a loser and nobody
as usual melvin accompanied by luke
comes to lucas to monitor his brains
activity and condition
at this point lucas urges melvin to
consult with a professional as he is not
capable of diagnosing what is happening
to his brain
however he refuses to do so
he is confident that he will be okay
while enjoying their afternoon they are
confronted by a local officer jimmy who
is worried about them
he reminds the superhero not to waste
his gifted power by constantly getting
high and doing nothing
melvin takes the advice and attempts to
use his power for something useful
he manages to take down robbers
effortlessly
however instead of returning the stolen
money he takes the money and spends it
on alcohol and drugs
during the party he feels severe pain in
his chest and passes out he is brought
to the hospital and luckily the doctor
is still able to save his life
as soon as he regains his consciousness
the doctor tells him that he suffered a
serious cardiac arrest and his heart
stopped beating for several minutes
after being discharged from the hospital
melvin realizes that he is wrong all the
time and intends to use his power to
fight crime
he is also committed to becoming sober
and hoping that he would meet his son
rex again
luke is happy hearing that and promises
he will give his full support to him
he returns to the lab and starts
practicing to use his telekinesis in a
proper way
he tries to bend a fork and a stop sign
without touching it after a while melvin
takes the practice into the next level
as he manages to solve a three by three
rubik's cube with his mind
melvin even goes to the gym to build
endurance and strength
luke also always presents beside him to
motivate him to get better
he goes to the scrap yard and practices
controlling heavy objects with his butt
in hand
unfortunately at this point he still can
only watch his son from a distance after
a series of exercises melvin does luke a
favor assisting him to impress a hot
girl called yolanda he performs a
lifting bag magic trick which shocks the
woman and she eventually gives her
number to him despite already having a
boyfriend
in the evening the gentleman pay a visit
to a friend's place where melvin makes
it clear that he has stopped drinking
his drunk friends surprisingly support
melvin after knowing the reason that he
wants to get clean for his son the
following day melvin silently follows
rex from behind and is enraged when he
finds out that the drug dealers sell
drugs to children he can't wait any
longer and confronts jimmy informing him
that he is now ready to do some good for
the community
the cop then approves his request
he returns to lucas's lab and this time
he manages to move the stop sign which
almost hits lucas
the teacher reminds him that he may need
more practice without thinking about the
consequences melvin confronts the drug
dealers and urges them to meet with the
leader nathan personally one of the
thugs takes out his knife and throws it
toward melvin but he easily stops the
knife and threatens them
afterward he attends a family dinner
where his sister introduces her
boyfriend ryan to her brother as
expected melvin scares the innocent man
with his power
ryan who doesn't know about melvin's
power leaves the house in fear
suddenly he is informed that lucille was
shot by nathan in retaliation
he immediately heads over to the
hospital where lucille and the others
are highly disappointed with melvin's
reckless action and tell him to leave
the room
after his one and only supporter is not
willing to meet him again melvin
abandons his intention to get clean and
start drinking again
jimmy approaches him in a pub to remind
him about his objective but melvin
doesn't care
later that night he stops by lucille's
house and apologizes to him
however he forbids him to get into the
house after realizing that melvin is
drunk a desperate sadness envelopes
melvin and he decides to go crazy again
at his friend's place partying all night
with girls
in the morning melvin and his friends
are attacked by nathan and the gang
luckily melvin reacts on time and
manages to block all the upcoming
bullets
afterward he feels the pain again in the
chest and meets lucas
the teacher concludes that the more he
uses his ability the more it will be
hurting him
when he urges the superhuman to see a
specialist suddenly lucille shows up and
reconciles with melvin
he pays a visit to rex's school
realizing that he must become a good man
if he wants to meet rex in person again
he then resumes his training in the
scrapyard and finally gains full control
over his ability
after gaining his confidence back he
comes to jimmy informing him that he is
going to launch a surprise attack on
nathan's place
while on his way he spots two crooks
robbing a store and pulls over to give
them some lessons
melvin eventually arrives at nathan's
hideout and starts wreaking havoc there
he effortlessly blocks all the bullets
and single-handedly eliminates all
nathan's henchmen with his telekinesis
power
he chases after a thug who tries to
escape to the building and tears down
the entire building after getting his
revenge melvin brings lucille back to
the scrapyard where he surprises his
friend with a new premium wheelchair
lucille tests driving to his new vehicle
and happiness while melvin disassembles
the old wheelchair
at the end of the movie melvin
approaches his ex-wife in request to see
rex
she initially refuses but after he shows
her the proof that he helps with his
child support doreen then reluctantly
agrees
melvin dresses up and finally gets the
chance to ride his son home
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching